so we all have our own biases for
example some of us tend to think that
it's very difficult to transform failing
government systems when we think of
government systems we tend to think that
their archaic said in their ways and
perhaps the leadership was just too
bureaucratic to be able to change things
well today I want to challenge that
theory I want to tell you a story of a
very large government system that has
not only put itself on the path of
reform but has also shown fairly
spectacular results in less than three
years this is what a classroom in a
public school in India looks like there
are 1 million Sat schools in India and
even for me who's lived in India all her
life walking into one of these schools
is fairly heartbreaking by the time kids
are 11 50% of them have fallen so far
behind in their education that they have
no hope to recover 11 year-olds cannot
do simple addition they cannot construct
a grammatically correct sentence these
are things that you and I would expect
an eight-year-old to be able to do by
the time kids are 13 or 14 they tend to
drop out of schools in India public
schools not only offer free education
they offer free textbooks free workbooks
free meals sometimes even cash
scholarships and yet 40% of the parents
today are choosing to pull their
children out of public schools and pay
out of their pockets to put them in
private schools as a comparison in a far
richer country the u.s. that number is
only 10% that's a huge statement on how
broken the Indian public education
system is so it was with that background
that I got a call in the summer of 2013
from an absolutely brilliant lady called
Serena Rajan she was at that time the
head of the department of school
education in a state called Haryana in
India so she said to us she said look
I've been heading this department for
the last two years I've tried a number
of things and nothing seems to work can
you possibly help let me describe her
IANA a little bit to you
Haryana is a state which has 30 million
people it has 15,000 schools public
schools and 2 million plus children in
those public schools so basically with
that phone call I promised to help a
state and a system which was as large as
that of Peru or Canada transformed
itself as I started this project I was
very painfully aware of two things one
that I had never done anything like this
before
and to many others had but perhaps
without too much success as my
colleagues and I looked across the
country and across the world
we couldn't find another example that we
could just pick up and replicate in
Haryana
we knew that we had to craft our own
journey but anyway we jumped right in
and as we jumped in all sorts of ideas
started flying at us you know people
said let's change the way we recruit
teachers let's hire new principals and
train them and send them on
international learning tours let's put
technology inside classrooms by the end
of week one we had 50 ideas on the table
all amazing all sounded right there was
no way we were going to be going to be
able to implement 50 things so I said
hang on stop let's first at least decide
what is it that we're trying to achieve
so with a lot of push and pull and
debate Haryana
said itself a goal which said by 2020 we
want 80 percent of our children to be at
grade level knowledge now the specifics
of the goal don't matter here but what
matters is how specific the goal is
because it really allowed us to take all
those ideas which were being thrown at
us and say which ones are we going to
implement does this idea support this
goal if yes let's keep it but if doesn't
or we're not sure then let's put it
aside as simple as it sounds having a
very specific goal right up front has
really allowed us to be very sharp and
focused in our transformation journey
and looking back
over the last two and a half years that
has been a huge positive for us so we
had the goal and now we needed to figure
out what are the issues what is broken
before we went into schools a lot of
people told us that education quality is
poor because either the teachers are
lazy they don't come into schools or
they're incapable they actually don't
know how to teach well when we went
inside schools we found something
completely different on most days most
teachers were actually inside schools
and when you spoke with them you realize
that they were perfectly capable of
teaching elementary classes but they
were not teaching I went to a school
where the teachers were getting the
construction of a classroom in a toilet
supervised I went to another school
where two of the teachers had gone to a
nearby Bank branch to deposit
scholarship money into kids accounts at
lunchtime most teachers were spending
all of their time getting the midday
meal cooking supervised and served to
the students so we asked the teachers we
said why what is going on why are you
not teaching and they said but this is
what's expected of us when a supervisor
comes to visit us these are exactly the
things that he checks has the toilet
been made has the meal been served when
my principal goes to a meeting at
headquarters these are exactly the
things which are discussed you see what
had happened was that over the last two
decades India had been fighting the
challenge of access having enough
schools and enrollments bringing
children into the schools so the
government launched a whole host of
programs to address these challenges and
the teachers became the implicit
executors of these think programs not
explicitly but implicitly and now what
was actually needed was not to actually
train teachers further or to monitor
their attendance but to tell them - that
what is most important is for them to go
back inside classrooms and teach they
needed to be monitored and measured and
avoided on the quality of teaching and
not on all sorts of other things so as
we went through the education system as
we
into a deeper we found a few such hole
root causes which were determining which
were shaping how people behaved in the
system and we realized that unless we
change those specific things we could do
a number of other things we could train
we could do put technology into schools
but the system wouldn't change and
addressing these non-obvious core issues
became a key part of the program so we
had the goal and we had the issues and
now we needed to figure out what the
solutions were we obviously did not want
to recreate the wheel so we said let's
look around and see what we can find and
we found these beautiful small pilots
experiments all over the country and all
over the world you know small things
being done by NGOs being done by
foundations but what was also
interesting was that none of them
actually scaled all of them were limited
to 50 hundred or 500 schools and here we
were looking for a solution for fifteen
thousand schools so we looked into why
if these things actually work why don't
they actually scale what happens is that
when a typical NGO comes in they not
only bring in their expertise but they
also bring in additional resources so
they might bring in money they might
bring in people they might bring in
technology and in the fifty or hundred
schools that they actually operate in
those additional resources actually
create a difference but now imagine that
the head of this NGO goes to the head of
the school education department and says
hey now let's do this for 15,000 schools
where is that guy or girl going to find
the money to actually scale this up to
15,000 schools he doesn't have the
additional money he doesn't have the
resources and hence innovations don't
scale so right at the beginning of the
project what we said was whatever we
have to do has to be scalable it has to
work in all 15,000 schools and hence it
has to work within the existing budgets
and resources that the state actually
has much easier said than done and I
think this was definitely the point of
time when my team hated me you know we
spent
a lot of long hours in office in cafes
sometimes even in bars scratching our
heads and saying where are the solutions
how are we going to solve this problem
in the end I think we did find solutions
to many of the issues I'll give you an
example in the context of effective
learning one of the things people talk
about is hands-on learning children
shouldn't memorize things from books
they should do activities and that's a
more effective way to learn which
basically means giving students things
like beads learning rods abacuses but we
did not have the budgets to give that to
15,000 schools two million children we
needed another solution couldn't think
of anything one day one of my team
members went to a school and saw a
teacher pick up sticks and stones from
the garden outside and take them into
the classroom and give them to the
students
that was a huge Eureka moment for us so
what happens now in the textbooks in
Haryana is that after every concept we
have a little box which are instructions
for the teachers would say hey to teach
this concept here's an activity that you
can do and by the way in order to
actually do this activity here are
things that you can use from your
immediate environment whether it be the
garden outside or the classroom inside
which can be used as learning aids for
kids and we see teachers all over
Haryana using lots of innovative things
to be able to teach students so in this
way we were able to whatever we designed
we were actually able to implement it
across all 15,000 schools from day one
now this brings me to my last point how
do you implement something across 15,000
schools and a hundred thousand teachers
the department used to have a process
which is very interesting I like to call
it the chain of Hope they would write a
letter from the headquarters and send it
to the next level which was the district
offices they would hope that in each of
this district offices an officer would
get the letter would open it read it and
then forwarded it to the next level
which was the block offices and then you
would hope that if the block
so somebody else got the letter opened
it read it and forwarded it eventually
to the 15,000 principals and then one
would hope that the principal's got the
letter received it understood it and
started implementing it it was a little
bit ridiculous now we knew technology
was the answer but we also knew that
most of these schools don't have a
computer or email however what the
teachers do have our smartphones they're
constantly on SMS on facebook and on
whatsapp so what now happens in Haryana
is all principals and teachers are
divided into hundreds of whatsapp groups
and anytime something needs to be
communicated
it's just posted across all whatsapp
groups it spreads like wildfire you know
you can immediately check who has
received it who has read it teachers can
ask clarification questions
instantaneously and what's interesting
is it's not just the headquarters were
answering these questions
another teacher from a completely
different part of the state will you
know stand up and answer the question
everybody is acting as everybody's peer
group and things are getting implemented
so today when you go to a school in
Haryana things look different
the teachers are back inside classrooms
they are teaching often with innovative
techniques when a supervisor comes to
visit the classroom he or she not only
checks the construction of the toilet
but also what is the quality of teaching
once a quarter all students across the
state are assessed on their learning
outcomes and schools which are doing
well
are rewarded and schools which are not
doing so well find themselves having
difficult conversations of course they
also get additional support to be able
to do better in the future in the
context of Education it's very difficult
to see results quickly when people talk
about systemic large-scale change they
talk about periods of seven years and
ten years but not in Haryana in the last
one year there have been three
independent studies on measuring student
learning outcomes which indicate that
something fundamental
something unique is happening in Haryana
learning levels of children have stopped
declining and they have started going up
Haryana is one of the few states in the
country which is showing an improvement
and certainly the one which is showing
the fastest rate of improvement these
are still early signs there's a long way
to go but this gives us a lot of hope
for the future I recently went to a
school and as I was leaving I ran into a
lady her name was Barbara thei she was
the mother of a child and she was
smiling and I said why are you smiling
what's going on and she said look I
don't know what's going on but what I do
know is that my children are learning
they're having fun and for the time
being I stopped my search for a private
school to send them to so I go back to
where I started can government systems
transform I certainly believe so I think
if you give them the right levers they
can move mountains thank